so we could go to our friend we go God
that guy was really good huh they're
like it's Harry Styles and I was like
who's and we're trying to tell him he's
a good singer and I'm like feels so dumb
Ashton Kutcher shares why he had to
apologize to Harry Styles after a night
of karaoke
things haven't been quite the same the
actress bills the details to Esquire
about his run-in with the singer during
a party there's an
extraordinarily well-known singer that
is maybe the best singer today that we
happen to be neighbors with and she was
throwing a karaoke part and she gets up
and does this like out of this world
bananas and I'm like this is just so
unfair and then this other kid gets up
and he does this like ABBA song
[Music]
your kid gets off stage and Mila and I
go up to him and we're like man
I gotta tell you something you're a
ringer you're definitely you're like a
karaoke ringer you're really good like
like really good and you're just like
thanks man thank you I really appreciate
that but little did Ashton know that guy
was kind of a big deal so we just go to
our friend we go God that guy was really
good huh they're like it's Harry Styles
and I was like who's
and Neil is like it's the guy from the
blue band he's like a professional
singer I was like oh my God now I feel
like a jerk he's a professional singer
and we're trying to tell him he's a good
singer
[Music]
and I'm like feels so dumb so I just
really want to say I'm sorry Harry
Styles but you're really good at karaoke
man
seriously like really good the fact that
that happened is insane but don't worry
Harry Ashton's got a bit of History here
with recognizing stars or lack thereof I
know that's Chris Pratt
Chris Hemsworth and Chris Evans
um and then Chris
I know
I know Chris Pine's really good friends
with a really a really good friend of
mine and so I met Chris Pine and I sat
next to him at a meal but he doesn't
look like Chris Pine in that photo I
can't even tell you one star Ashton does
keep up with Reese Witherspoon I am very
lucky they pay our co-stars in a new
Netflix rom-com your place or mine
hey Debbie happy birthday Peter 20 years
of friendship can you believe it how do
you still speak to me do you remember
the first night we met
foreign
[Music]
was that the big draw for you to return
to this genre was that we need kind of
more of this levity and it was that it
was the idea of working with the queen
did working with Ashton for the first
time live up to your expectations Rhys I
mean it was so fun in this perfect movie
we both had equal parts that's a big
piece of it too I think so a lot of
rom-coms don't know how to balance and
this one was just a 50 50 movie and so
we both felt responsible for making it
funny and better and endearing and real
and grounded and so I think it was just
and I'm so glad it's on Netflix too
because I feel like it's just gonna be
everybody can see it
[Music]